[Music]
on this Thursday night anxiety mounts
over the spread of Koba 19 from a major
market meltdown two new travel bans this
virus is not influenza one country takes
swift action the risk of a global
pandemic is very much upon us and the
u.s. reports a new mysterious case
high-stakes talks between with so itand
hereditary chiefs and government
ministers plus why no one's enforcing a
court order to break up this barricade
and saving the North Atlantic right
whales we are confident that these
measures will be effective Ottawa's plan
to protect and preserve and endangered
species
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
even if you aren't sick with the virus
and don't know anyone who is kovat 19 is
beginning to disrupt lives around the
world well beyond the epicenter in China
from flight cancellations and travel
restrictions to warnings of serious
economic implications millions of people
are feeling the effects of what's become
an international health crisis there are
now confirmed cases in at least 50
countries following a formation toss
back home to see who's in France where
there are 38 known cases the president
told doctors today an epidemic is coming
and to prepare for it the biggest
outbreaks outside Asia are still in
Italy and Iran but almost every hour
another country confirms new cases the
potential impact has spooked investors
so much the investment bank Goldman
Sachs forecasts American companies will
see zero earnings growth in 2020 in New
York the Dow Jones plummeted almost
1,200 points that's the biggest one-day
point decline in history in Toronto
there were huge sell offs - on the TSX
it dropped more than 300 points before
trading was abruptly halted for the day
the exchange blamed technical issues
here's what's also fueling fears
thousands of people in California are
being monitored for signs of kovat 19
they may have come into contact with a
woman who tested positive there and she
was sick for a week before she was
tested how she got the virus is a
mystery officially there are 60
confirmed cases in the US but it's clear
now not everyone who should be tested is
being tested
Jaxson Prosecco on the trouble that is
causing in Northern California a new
kovat 19 mystery a woman with no history
of travel and no contact with known
patients has tested positive for the
virus she's in hospital and on a
ventilator
the person who exposed them probably
exposed others so there's probably other
cases out there in the community that we
don't know about it may be the first
case of community transmission in the
u.s. exposing a huge gap in the American
response despite being in hospital and
having all the symptoms the woman wasn't
originally tested for Co vid 19 because
she didn't need
strict US government criteria the exact
scenario experts have warned about I'm
very concerned about the level of
testing and I'm puzzled about the level
of testing if a country like South Korea
can do tens of thousands of tests I do
not understand why in our country we
have managed to barely 500 more than
8,000 people in California are now being
monitored for symptoms as the u.s.
scrambles to ramp up its testing ability
but in Washington the response to the
virus has been defiant I don't think
it's inevitable on Wednesday the
president contradicted his own experts
and proclaimed the US would soon have
almost no cases of the virus we're going
to be pretty soon at only five people
and we could be at just one or two
people over the next short period of
time Wall Street isn't buying it the Dow
took another steep dive continuing its
rapid decline into correction territory
while the White House reportedly
considered enacting special wartime
measures to increase production of masks
and protective equipment for medical
workers officials have warned supplies
are woefully inadequate there's also a
heavy focus on managing public
perception US government scientists and
officials have been told they can't
speak publicly or to the press until
they coordinate with the office of the
vice president the man overseeing
Trump's coronavirus response Donna all
right Jackson Prosecco in Washington
thanks right now the most deaths outside
China are in Iran a major religious
gathering there has been canceled Friday
prayers have been called off in Tehran
and several other cities as well to try
to limit the spread after a dramatic
jump in confirmed cases the official
number in Iran is 245 and 26 deaths and
it's spreading through senior Iranian
officials after Iran's deputy Health
Minister who kept working while visibly
sick and then tested positive at least
five others are now ill including a
female vice president and a prominent
cleric who has died
crystal gammon Singh has details on the
global spread of this virus
the crowds have vanished the novel
coronavirus is scaring away customers
from the cafes and shops of Italy
Venice is on its knees says this
business owner we don't know how to
react more than 600 people in Italy are
infected and covet night scene has
caused 3 more deaths in the Lombardy
region simply oh thank you so know the
governor there is infected and is
updating people on his condition by
posting videos online the epidemics in
the Islamic Republic of Iran Italy and
the Republic of Korea demonstrate what
this virus is capable of but this virus
is not influenza with the right measures
it can be contained but it's not being
contained South Korea with the largest
one-day infection spike since January
20th set up drive through screening
centers nearly 9,000 kilometers away
another mobile site this one in London
where again more cases have been
detected Australia's Prime Minister
outlined his country's plan to protect
public health and he didn't shy away
from the seriousness of the virus whu-oh
is yet to declare the nature of the
corona virus and it's moved towards a
pandemic phase we believe that the risk
of a global pandemic is very much upon
us mitigating risks is a key and for the
first time Saudi Arabia is banning all
foreign pilgrims become the lehtinen
officials say we feel a sense of
responsibility
therefore we took these temporary
decisions which will constantly be
reviewed a full ban wasn't even
implemented for the Ebola outbreak in
2014 throughout the year millions of
Muslims head to the kingdom for
pilgrimages and there's no timeframe for
when this ban might be lifted crystal de
Manson Global News London
here in Canada there are still no deaths
linked to Kovan 19 the number of
confirmed cases though grew today to 13
a man in Toronto has tested positive
public health officials believe the man
in his 60s contracted the virus from his
wife she tested positive after returning
from Iran the couple is now at home in
self isolation federal officials say the
risk of contracting the virus here in
Canada remains low as for traveling to
other countries where the risk is higher
there are some things you should know
we've got some helpful tips on our
website Global News CA / global national
there's no indication this is related
but Pope Francis skipped a mass plan for
today because he's feeling unwell
yesterday during Ash Wednesday Mass the
83 year old was coughing and blowing his
nose he shook hands and kissed babies in
st. Peter's Square and in his message to
the crowd the Pope offered his sympathy
to victims of the corona virus the
Vatican said today he's slightly unwell
and preferred to work from home now to
the rail blockades in Canada a federal
minister is in northern BC meeting those
with so itand hereditary chiefs who
don't want a natural gas pipeline
crossing their territory and the RCMP
have agreed to suspend their patrols
along a service road there a resolution
could lead to an end to the rail
blockades elsewhere in the country
Sarah MacDonald is in Smithers BC where
those talks are taking place the eyes of
the nation were on this tarmac in
northern BC Thursday
and one high-profile passenger in
particular we're looking forward to the
meeting Carolyn Bennett's representing
the federal government in high-stakes
talks with indigenous leaders ready to
come to the table what was that
misunderstanding I was in there I was on
my way but not providing details on why
talks setting the stage for a
nation-to-nation meeting were abruptly
called off on Wednesday where the when
Snowden hereditary chiefs asked to call
for an end to the blockades across
Canada with the RCMP now pulling its
members off this polarized parcel of
indigenous land and work briefly halted
on the natural gas pipelines sparking
unrest nationwide the traditional
leaders of what so in a nation fiercely
opposed to the 6.6 billion dollar
project that's backed by band councils
and all levels of government say they're
open to dialogue we did not want it to
get to this point of disruption but that
was actually the federal and provincial
government but the Chiefs won't call for
an end to blockades like these crippling
rail traffic and parts of the Canadian
economy for weeks drawing the ire and
condemnation of many with so it in
people like Mary until Joe Shepherds I
am poor at the pipeline I am poor
industry banking on the benefits and
prosperity promised by that pipeline
people just want to work our community
wants to work and I think the benefits
are going to be really important to our
people with livelihoods on the line
exactly how it will proceed and with
what level of support if any from those
determined to stop it all depends on
what happens behind these closed doors
and if a resolution will be reached
remains a major question mark at this
point Donna both sides are calling this
an important first step in what will
likely be a lengthy process all right
Sarah McDonald in Smithers VC thanks in
Tyendinaga Ontario protesters were back
at it today trying to set a fire along
the tracks yesterday a fire caused a
freight train to stop some people
taunted a train standing on the tracks
trying to block it there were no arrests
but questions are being raised about who
should be held accountable for reckless
and potentially
dangerous acts our Mike droll a is there
tonight Mike
Donna tensions have been high here in
Thai and Onegin with Mohawk protesters
on one side of the tracks OPP on the
other but this weather seems to have
cooled things down a bit today the
extreme winds and cold have for the most
part kept both sides seeking shelter it
was a quiet Thursday morning in
Tyendinaga the trains ran smoothly and
unempioyed as extreme winds and cold
kept protesters in their tents but
mid-afternoon the Mohawk anger flared up
protesters threw wood on the tracks
which the Ontario Provincial Police
promptly removed protesters that
attempted delayed a fire next to a
passing train but the winds blew it out
and so it continues a back-and-forth
that Federal Transport Minister Marc
Garneau says has resulted in a log jam
of a hundred and eighty four trains
sitting idle confrontation seemed
inevitable Wednesday as Mohawks played
chicken with passing trains while
lighting fires with wood pallets and
further away an SUV no arrests were made
leading many to question why Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau called it
reckless yet stop short of saying the
Ontario Provincial Police Officers
dedicated to the territory should make
arrests for its part the government is
unequivocal that it wasn't terrorism the
kinds of reckless things that were done
yesterday are dangerous particularly if
dangerous goods and trains carry a lot
of dangerous goods are involved an
interview with one of the protesters
arrested on Monday was posted on social
media
Nicole bazooka spoke of the OPP s
heavy-handed approach and they said put
your arm behind your back I said I can't
you're standing on it he said he was
hoping to avoid conflict I think he
believes most Canadians don't understand
the issues at hand our laws our
traditions were here before Canadian
laws and Canadian governments most of us
are fine as long as they can learn to
live in harmony with us live in peace
with us and respect our laws and our
traditions
now the Mohawks haven't been speaking to
the media but all day they've been
loading up on supplies seemingly
preparing to stay here
for the long haul
okay Mike trollee thanks québec's
premier Francois logo is refusing to
apologize for suggesting some in Ghana
waka are armed with assault rifles there
is growing solidarity in the Mohawk
territory south of Montreal where
demonstrators have been blocking rail
traffic for nearly three weeks that's
where our Mike Armstrong is tonight just
around the corner up the hill from this
checkpoint Mohawks have blocked a set of
tracks normally there'd be both commuter
and freight trains running through
they're not it's been 18 days and
Counting for this blockade and no one's
leaving Oh
tremendous solidarity tremendous and and
every time somebody tries to escalate it
gets better no that talk of escalation
is a reference to something quebec's
premier said Wednesday explaining why
police weren't acting to remove the
blockade press one ago said it was
because there are dangerous weapons on
the gondola a reserve things like he
said a que 47 he tried to paint us as as
being violent and armed and we're not
you've been here some of you've been
here a long time you haven't seen any
any weapons or anything like that you
know they're not here the premier isn't
retracting or apologizing his office
says the situation is delicate but that
he was telling the truth
and trying to inform Quebecers well it
is clear no external police force is
going on to the reserve to take down the
barricade in fact there is a court
injunction ordering the blockade be
lifted but no one's delivering the
document that will be stupid saying
first of all that we fear that it could
be a confrontation our armed
confrontation and now we will have
someone to show up with paper that would
be stupid
no the reserve is policed by an
indigenous force in fact the gonorrhoeae
peacekeepers say they're the only
indigenous force in Canada staffed
exclusively by indigenous officers it
would fall to them to enforce the court
order they've decided they will not we
live here we work here we have family
here this is our home and we believe in
supporting our people and we're going to
continue to do that the protesters are
following the situation in BC and if
there's progress they're ready to lift
the blockade but not they say before
Mike Armstrong global news no no Augie
go back a severe storm hits Quebec
coming up the terrifying winter wipeout
for one truck driver
in Edmonton as the government was
tabling its budget today teachers nurses
doctors and other public sector workers
marched to the legislature angry about
cuts to public services that premier
Jason Kenny's government has already
made and fearing more are coming Kenny
has promised to balance the books and
this was the second budget in four
months
Alberta is suffering through a prolonged
downturn in the oil and gas sector the
province is still facing an almost 7
billion dollar deficit but as Heather
Eurex west reports Alberta's finance
minister is counting on an upswing in
fortunes to bring in more revenue
Alberta's budget 2020 is being called a
plan for jobs and the economy but at its
heart its focus is on oil and gas 2019
was a tough year but there are signs of
life one pipeline line three began to
come online in December though it will
take one more
either trans Mountain or Keystone to get
Alberta the market access it needs
betting that will happen the province is
forecasting oil revenues will double by
2023
hindsight's going to be 2020 but but as
I look ahead and again when I evaluate
every one of those revenue lines and
take a look at our underlying
assumptions that have informed our
revenue projections I don't believe
we're being over optimistic to help with
the recovery there are a few new tools
corporate tax cuts announced in 2019
will go even lower and the government
promises to keep pressuring Ottawa for a
so-called fair deal in fact budget 2020
features an entire chapter on this fight
we share the frustration of so many
Albertans when we've been a province
who's made an absolute outsized
contribution to Confederation and then
we see a federal government implement
policies that are absolutely contrary to
the economic interests and to the
interests of Albertans and I would
suggest the interest of Canadians that's
why we've devoted a chapter to it what
isn't in this budget any kind of direct
public investment in the energy sector
and there's nothing to account for the
emerging threat of coronavirus as the
threat of a worldwide pandemic begins to
impact the global demand for oil
ultimately we can't predict where the
coronavirus and the economic effects
will land quite frankly
but what we can do is we can manage the
variables that this province can manage
ahead why Canada won't be picking up the
tab anymore for Harry and Megan security
this winter storm is hitting Quebec and
it's forced schools and flight
cancellations across the province the
whiteout is made for some dangerous
driving conditions to this semi truck
nearly slid right off a Quebec City
Highway the same storm system is making
travel difficult in parts of Ontario
where people are being urged to avoid
non-essential travel the province is
bracing for snow squalls and
blizzard-like conditions into the
weekend
remember that false emergency alert
about a nuclear station in Ontario
earlier this year well a new report by
the Ontario government blames human
error the alert about the Pickering
Nuclear Station was sent to cell phones
radios and TVs across the province On
January 12th
it took 108 minutes to let people know
it was a false alarm
a report from the chief of emergency
management Ontario blames communications
failures procedural gaps and a lack of
training for the error Canadian
taxpayers will soon no longer be paying
to protect the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex Public Safety Minister Bill Blair
confirmed today the RCMP has been
obligated since November to provide
security to the royal couple who are
considered internationally protected
persons Harry Megan and baby Archie
settled into a mansion north of Victoria
in BC but at the end of March they will
formally relinquish their royal
privileges and when their status changes
so will their security balance in the
bays next Ottawa's struggled to protect
the fragile species and support workers
at sea
the future of the endangered North
Atlantic right whale is still deeply
uncertain only 400 remain and at least
30 right whales have died in the last
three years most of them in Canadian
waters they're being struck by ships or
becoming entangled in fishing gear
now as Ross Lord reports the federal
government has imposed strict new rules
to protect the fragile population with
their critically low numbers at risk of
declining even further the future of
North Atlantic right whales is largely
in the hands of legislators federal
politicians sorting out how the whales
can coexist with cargo ships and fish
harvesters our number one focus is we
want to try to really bring down to zero
the risk to the North Atlantic whales we
are confident that these measures will
be effective the new rules including
closing fishing zones for the entire
season in areas where right whales
gather expanding temporary closures into
the Bay of Fundy
requiring more fish harvesters to mark
their gear and reimposing speed limits
on cargo ships whale researchers say the
rules are similar to previous years but
I think they've kind of refined them so
I think they're gonna be a lot more
pointed and perhaps try and be a bit
more effective for crab fishers whose
catches might suffer during the summer
there is an opportunity to start their
season early and avoid contact with the
whales the hope is that people can be in
and out before the North Atlantic right
whales return to Canadian waters
researchers say ten right whale calves
have been born over the winter in the
waters of the southern United States
which equals the number killed last
summer in Canadian waters they're doing
their part to make sure that they're
continuing the population we need to
make sure we're doing our part
a new search for symmetry on the C's
Ross lowered global news Halifax and
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm donor Friesen tonight's
your Canada is booked to New Brunswick
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at global national
calm thanks for watching hope to see you
here again tomorrow bye bye
[Applause]
Oh